hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and in this video I want to talk to you
about sick codes a sick code is
something that you will need to give to
a company's house when you set up a
company and there's many of you of my
subscribers that are losing thousands of
pounds and months and months of wasted
time messing around because you're
getting caught out by putting the wrong
sit code on your company's house form so
this is something I was thinking for a
long time shall I do a video on this to
YouTube and just share to the whole of
YouTube I've been holding this back and
I've been keeping this for my sort of
inner circle Advanced students but I
just couldn't bear it anymore when I was
seeing people messaging me on Instagram
saying oh man I've used this sick code
and as a result I've had to close my
bank down and I just thought man I'm
going to share this for the whole of
YouTube so this is an extremely
important video save it to your
favorites share it around because you do
not want to use the wrong sick code and
then I'm getting bust so firstly what is
a zip code a Sit code stands for a
standard in
classification nation of economic
activity wow what a mouthful what does
that mean that means companies house the
government they want to know what your
business is doing they want to know the
classification of the business so when
you set up your company on companies
house you'll set it up you'll pay your
12 pounds 50. you'll give your details
your address you'll tell them what your
company is going to be called my company
is going to be called you know Samuel
leads property Investments limited and
then you'll say what's the ZIP code and
it will give you a list and you'll
scroll through pages and pages of
different sit codes with different
businesses and most people scroll
through and they just choose the one
that seems most appropriate so let's say
you're doing deal sourcing or you're
doing rent to rent or you're buying
properties these are some of the sick
codes so there's zip code
68100 which is for the buying and
selling of your own real estate zip code
68209 it's for the letting and operating
of own or leased real estate zip code
68230 is for the management of real
estate on a field contract basis sick
code 68310 is for real estate agencies
so there's all these different sick
codes and you might think it's much of a
much nurse who cares I'll just choose
one no this is where people are getting
absolutely busted when you're doing
let's say rent to rent now this is a
specifically legal issue right now when
you're doing Rental rent question is
what are you are you a management
company
managing the property for the landlord
in which case if you're a management
company then you should go under on
68320 which is for the management of
real estate on a field contract basis
but here's the problem with that the way
that we do rent to rent and the way that
I teach and my students do rent to rent
they're not a management company because
if you're a management company then
suddenly you are restricted by
management rules you now need to be
registered with anti-money laundering
before you can start trading you now
need to be registered with a redress
Ombudsman scheme you now need insurances
all these different things because
you've put yourself down as a management
company so if you're doing Rental rent
and again this is not Financial advice
this is just me telling you from my
experience what is smoother but if
you're doing Rental rent we put
ourselves down with zip code
68209 which is for the letting and
operating of own or leased real mistake
that's what it is because if you're a
company layer and you're renting a
property and then you've got an
agreement where you can rent it you're
not actually a management company you're
not managing that property you're
renting it from them with an agreement
that you can rent it out Samuel what's
the difference companies house don't
care anyway companies house don't mind
if you mix these up you are correct
there's no fines or penalties if you get
the wrong ZIP code but where you'll get
tripped up is if you put your management
company what will happen is when you set
your business up the first thing that a
business needs to do is what is to set
up a bank so you're going to set a bank
and the bank will say oh you're a
management company before we can open up
your bank please could you tell us your
anti-money laundering number could you
tell us this and you're like what don't
eat that stuff and they'll say yes
because you use the wrong sick code this
is why it's so important so now you
can't trade now you're like oh my
goodness I can't even open up a bank I'm
gonna need to get anti-money laundering
and this and this you don't need
antimony laundering unless you're taking
payments for over 9 000 Euros or unless
you are
a real estate agent or management
company you're not now again I can't say
you're not maybe you are maybe in your
contracts you're using contracts that
says you're a management company so
there's a lot here to think about to
make sure that you are doing things
technically correct if you're an estate
agent or a letting agency or a property
manager and you haven't got anti-money
laundering and you're not covered by a
redress to have the relevant insurances
that you need that cost hundreds or
maybe even thousands of pounds then
you're operating illegally because
estate agents have to be covered by
those things and you're saying on your
sick code that you chose
I'm an estate agent I'm an estate agent
look it's on my company's house but then
you haven't got those other bits and
Bobs now you're trading illegally and
operating illegally why because you've
got the wrong sick code and the
consequences of operating and trading
illegally can be huge with huge fines so
that's why it's really important to get
the right sick code to begin with and
that's what I'm doing this video by the
way if you enjoyed the video so far hit
like again deal sourcing if you're a
deal sourcer you might just think okay
I'm a deal sourcer I'll use sick code
68310 which says real estate agencies
same problem if you are a real estate
agency
you need anti-money laundering you need
this this this you're now an estate
agent you are saying you are an estate
agent are you an estate agent maybe you
are I don't know the way that I do deal
selling I'm not an estate agent when I
do deal selling is I work with estate
agents and I'll negotiate on behalf of
the investor I'm offering business
services and support to my investor and
I'm sort of okay what are you looking
for Mr investor are you looking for a
house that you can do this this is all
right I'll negotiate with the agent I'll
view the properties and then I'll
connect the agent and I'll connect the
investor and I'll charge a fee that is
not me being an estate agent and if I
say I'm an estate agent similarly woof
I've got all this added compliance and
red tape which might be unnecessary so
when I set up my deal sourcing company
I'm using the sick code
82990 which is other business support
business support
my investors are buying these properties
as a business investment and I am
offering support and services to help
negotiate a good price and connect them
to the agent who uses the ZIP code that
is different from my ZIP code so if I'm
doing deal selling I'm using the sick
code
82990 if I'm doing rent to rent the way
that I do rent to rent I'm using the
sick code
68209 if I'm buying properties myself
like if I'm doing buy refurbish
refinance I've got a company that's
investing in property then I'm going to
use the sick code 68100 which is for the
buying and selling of your own real
estate so that is a mini crash course on
sync codes if you've enjoyed the video
hit like if you want to learn more about
how to build up a property portfolio
from scratch set up a company get deals
and you want the step-by-steps of how to
do it properly and professionally then
come and join me at the property
investors crash course because that's
where it all starts it all starts at the
craft course tickets are one pound I'll
leave a link in the description I'll see
you there let's build let's build
properly and let's do this
[Music]